from the guy who brought you teddy
Perkins and this is America comes a show
so unhinged I was like
[Music]
[Applause]
Amazon's swarm is a supremely messed up
character study on Obsession addiction
and a reminder to never mess with
Beyonce fans in this video we'll be
taking a deep dive into the hive it's
ending and some of the real-life
inspiration for swarm so sit back grab
some delicious pie because here we go
swarm is not your traditional narrative
told across seven episodes at roughly 35
minutes each it's a character study into
Andrea Dre green a young black woman in
her obsession with influential pop star
naija the name naija comes from Arabic
meaning a beautiful rose apt considering
she becomes Dre's object of affection
but to fully understand how Dre's
Obsession manifests and how she turns
into a pie eating serial killer we have
to understand where Dre came from in an
interview with variety co-creator and
showrunner Janine Nabors refers to Dre
as an alien in fact in episode 1 you can
see a documentary about aliens in the
background Dre is an alien in her own
world she is different and yearns for
acceptance and this acceptance stems
from her abandonment as a child a lot of
Dre's upbringing is a mystery in fact
the showrunner says quote there's a
mystery as to how Dre got to where she
was and that's okay it's okay to not
know everything so while we may not have
answers to what made Dre The Monster she
becomes we do have some clues that paint
a very tragic picture according to Dre
or Tony as Dre goes by in the last
episode Drake's parents are dead they
lived on a farm where Dre says the sight
of blood was common however we can't
take any of this at face value because
we know Dre is an unreliable narrator
sometimes we'll see things from her
perspective and it's a hallucination
such as the time she thinks she's eating
a fruit when in fact she's biting naija
after sneaking into the after party at
some point Dre went to live with her
grandmother and as we learn from Eva's
therapy session at episode 4 there was
some sort of abrupt death it's not known
whether Drake killed her grandmother or
witnessed a terrible accident but we do
know it was with her grandmother that
she first heard naija there's mention of
milk being the color red her
grandmother's blood Dre refers to her
grandmother's blood as spilled milk
something she'll also use to describe
the aftermath of the slumber party
stabbing she was sorry she spilled the
milk
I didn't know what that meant it's
totally within the realm of possibility
that Dre dissociates and instead of
seeing Blood on the floor it's spilled
milk just like how she thought she was
seeing a fruit but it was Niger and how
we'll later see naija but with Marissa's
face but we'll unpack that whole can of
worms in a bit not much is known about
this grandmother's death but shortly
after Dre was put into foster care this
is where she is adopted by The Jacksons
the sad thing about this story is that
she was adopted not because this family
wanted her but they needed a paycheck as
Harris Jackson tells her in episode 5
between his mother's medical bills and
failing business they were in desperate
need of money and when you take someone
into foster care you get money to help
pay for the child so already this is not
an ideal situation this was not a
decision made out of the goodness of
their heart yet Dre and Marissa became
good friends the two of them bonded over
their love for naija however Dre was
still seen as a weirdo at school we see
some home video footage of her being
ridiculed at the school's talent show in
an interview with a fellow classmate 2
talks about her with disdain but I guess
that's what happens when your neck is
nearly broken and you're stabbed by Dre
yes at a slumber party Dre believes
Marissa is in danger and completely goes
off on Gwen here putting her in the
hospital this is the event that triggers
The Jacksons to return Dre to foster
care Harris also had a suspicion that
Dre was a lesbian and didn't want that
around his daughter so this provided him
a reason to get rid of her unbeknownst
to the Jacksons Marissa would later go
on to live with Trey in Houston and it's
mersa's subsequent suicide which is the
main catalyst for Dre's downward spiral
using a credit card Dre purchases two
tickets to naija one as a gift for
Marissa but Marissa tells her she can't
go because she'll be in Atlanta with her
boyfriend this is a huge blow for Dre
who sees the only person who's been kind
to her her entire life slowly being
ripped away by this [__] boyfriend so
she decides to go for a night on the
town but her phone runs out of battery
when Marissa needs her the most in an
earlier scene we see a scar on Marissa
his wrist suggesting that she attempted
suicide in the past the boyfriend cheats
on Marissa but Dre is nowhere to be
found when she needs her so when Dre
finds Marissa's seemingly overdosed she
blames herself for not being there
because of her past Dre isn't even
allowed to attend the funeral this leads
her to spiral out of control eventually
killing Khalid Maurice's ax as an act of
Revenge this is followed by her reaching
into the fridge and devouring a pie even
as she has blood still all over her
hands the show doesn't give us an
explanation for this but food
particularly junk food is a common Motif
throughout the season in her interview
with variety the showrunner states that
serial killers like Jeffrey Dahmer and
The Night Stalker had strange
connections with food so Dre's
connection seems to be heavily inspired
by these guys Dahmer for example worked
at a chocolate factory where some
believe he disposed of bodies in
chocolate while The Night Stalker would
rummage through the fridges of those he
murdered food becomes a method to which
Drake can disassociate from the world it
takes her mind off the violent traumatic
experience she just went through with
the death of Khalid Dre begins a violent
Journey that takes her all across the
country with each murder with the
exception of the ones in episode 4 being
inspired by actual real life events
Rashida's death was inspired by a murder
on the outskirts of Georgia in 2018
about a woman's body that was found in a
wooded area here are the strippers
wanted for murder from the events of
episode 2 but the show doesn't really
hold back is naija's connection to
Beyonce in episode 6 they actually bleep
out Beyonce's name and blur out the
posters of her on the wall there are
references to an obsessed fan rushing
the stage at a Jay-Z concert where
Beyonce was on stage we see Becky with
the good hair a fierce pillow a 2007
Beyonce Experience ticket not to mention
Beyonce was born in Houston where much
of the show takes place also I just love
the totally not subtle Helen talk show
by the time we get to episode 7 Dre's
Journey has her in remission or at least
that's what it looks like she doesn't
have a phone it feels more comfortable
in her sexuality and establish is what
seems to be a healthy relationship with
a woman named Rashida even when Rashida
tells her on night one that she doesn't
like naija Dre doesn't kill her it's
only until [__] hits a fan later on that
Dre relapses and we get the show's wild
ending much like Dre wanted to surprise
Marissa with naija tickets in episode 1
we've come full circle with Dre
surprising Rashida with tickets now
Rashida is understandably pissed she's
told Dre multiple times that she hates
naija and has grown to resent Dre who
constantly brings naija up as one of
their top five topics of conversation in
their relationship not to mention Dre is
broke Rasheed has been paying her cut of
the rent and those tickets are thousands
of dollars Rashida can't believe how
selfish Dre is and goes off on her
resulting in Trey strangling her to
death she just wanted to share naija
with her because she loves her
unfortunately Dre forgets that the
tickets she bought are now on the
burning corpse of Rashida and if she's
going to make that concert she must
devise a new way inside so she does what
any rational person would do you and
kills a scalper at the concert Dre
approaches the stage as if in some sort
of Trance but what transpires next is
all a hallucination Niger orders
security to let Dre go and in one of the
weirdest moments of the entire show
naija's face is that of Marissa Dre's
two obsessions have molded into one her
two loves have literally combined in
episode 1 Drey makes a promise to
Marissa that they'll one day meet her
and this is a [__] up way of
fulfilling that we have to meet him one
day promise me
we will I promise Niger assert is saying
a call back to her talent show the two
leave the concert together with Dre
saying thank you as she cries on naija's
chest this hearkens back to Dre's dream
of meeting naija in episode one and
she'll invite us back to her house for
dinner
I could feel it this is her dream of
being invited back to naija's with her
best friend but in reality she's
probably being taken to jail in the back
of a police car it's likely Dre will be
put away for good we have a detective on
our case and now two more bodies that of
the scalper and Rashida that can easily
be traced back to her what started as a
story about Obsession in Houston ends as
a story about Obsession in Houston it
has come full circle but what did you
think of swarm is it worth a watch or is
this a pass let me know in the comments
below thanks for watching everyone be
sure to like And subscribe and for more
bad takes you can follow me on Twitter
and Instagram at thinkstoryyt until next
time remember okay our job here is to
make this horn
thank you